[Applause]
soccer is the most popular sport in the
world and for soccer fans there's a
collectible item that's taking their
world by storm the panini soccer sticker
album that comes out every four years
we'll let this guy explain how it works
because well he wrote an entire book
about stickers my name is greg lansdowne
and i'm the author of stuck on you the
story of football stickers
[Applause]
[Music]
okay greg so what's this all about well
it's a very simple concept you start off
with the album and from there you need
to collect packets of stickers for the
world cup there's five stickers in every
packet in this particular world cup
album there's 682 spaces to fill and the
the idea or the name of the game is to
fill up the sticker album
once you start getting doubles of
stickers that's when the real fun
element comes in and you start swapping
with people
panini's first album mexico 70 started
off with the album being distributed in
just a few european countries that's now
grown and you can get panini stickers in
over a hundred countries worldwide and
that's that's growing every single
tournament
i'm sure they will leave no stone
unturned to make sure that you get
stickers in the hands of everyone around
the world ultimately
who is the biggest collector in the
world well there is a gentleman in italy
the home of panini stickers his name is
gianni bellini and his his sticker
collection is that needs to be seen to
be believed introducing gianni
bellini
gianni lives in a small town in italy
which happens to be only 20 miles from
the panini factory
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so there you have it if you didn't know
about soccer stickers now you can kick
your own collection into high gear
[Music]
you